SPEAKER 1: You may spend a
lot of your time writing code.
I certainly do.
With every keystroke, you and I
are creating future liability.
The code we write has to be
tested, deployed, debugged,
maintained, stored,
and, one day, retired.
That's expensive.
What we really want is
to process business data.
Code is just a way to get
there, but there are other ways.
Here's how I reduce the amount
of code I have to write.
One, I use Cloud Run to
go serverless instead
of mucking about with servers.
Two, I use Google
Cloud Workflows
to orchestrate my
services with simple YAML,
instead of with code.
Three, I let my users enter
and view data in Google Sheets,
instead of building
custom interfaces.
Four, I use Google Data
Studio to create dashboards,
instead of building
them with code.
Five, I use AppSheet to
create data-centric apps
with zero code.
What's your favorite
way to reduce code?
Let me know in the comments.